et bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
tvd monatélé actualité spécial chorus
chorus le tournoi le plus fort du monde
avec celui de bim ares alors pour
commander pour commenter donc pas pour
commander pour commenter ce chorus
on reçoit aujourd'hui pour la deuxième
fois dans un journal tv jérôme nous
frappons jour jérôme bonjour stéphane ça
va bien ça va alors donc tu suis un peu
ce que vous quand même j'ai suivi un
petit peu pas dire de très près j'ai
regardé les parties au fur et à mesure
bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'il ya deux trois grands
joueurs qui ne sont pas présents mais la
densité est très très forte
on sait que ce tournoi attire toujours
beaucoup les grands maîtres comme le
tournoi de linares même le tournoi b est
intéressant à suivre aussi les cieux on
a éventuellement des révélations de ce
qu'ils vont plus tard jouer le chorus et
non mais je crois aussi plus faisable si
on retrouve short et gilet des joueurs
qui ont été candidats au titre mondial
aux années 80 90 et 1b super super belle
à super besse un avis plutôt bien a dit
c'est quoi aussi comme s'ils avaient
deux tournois par sk quasiment
définitive alors donc super tournoi
chorus évidemment chaque fois donc on va
voir si aujourd'hui on va on va en
reparler de toi pour ceux qui nous
auraient pas suivi la première la
première semaine donc on va rappeler que
tu es tu prof d'histoire bon évidemment
tu membre du comité directeur de la
fédération française écrit dans l'échec
et mat notamment et puis alors tu es
donc au sein de l'académie de créteil
chargé du développement du jeu d'échecs
de l'académie de créteil seine saint
denis
de marne marne seine et marne donc pour
pour
à développer un jeu d'échecs en tant
qu'outil pédagogique pour le
développement de la concentration et des
qualités pédagogiques pour lui pour les
enfants
absolument c'est ça de la grande section
de maternelle c'est à dire les enfants
de ce1 de cinq ans jusqu'à la fac c'est
à dire 18 20 ans alors il ya tout à
faire évidemment on est dans la deuxième
plus grande académie de france peut-être
l'académie qui au plan politique a le
plus d'importance parce qu'elle sait
celle qui est le plus sous le feu des
médias notamment pour des raisons
symboliques à cause de ce qui se passe
en seine saint denis du ministre j'ai
envie de dire jusqu'à l'homme de la rue
tout le monde attend qu'ils aient des
résultats probants dans l'éducation sur
cette zone donc le jeu d'échecs a un
vrai rôle en élargissant à jouer un rôle
puissant à jouer la fédération d'appui
sur ce site et sur la fédération l'appui
le elle ce ne serait pas ma disposition
mais en tout cas elle se met à
disposition du rectorat pour favoriser
tout ça je rappelle que la fédération
nous a soutenus notamment dans
l'organisation d'un grand tournoi à
villepinte
oui on est dans financièrement et
techniquement aussi j'ai je reçois en
appui très très fort de la fédération
bien sûr qui a signé une convention en
mars 2007 avec l'éducation nationale
oui une convention qui grand le jeu
d'échec je dirais cesser ces matières
officielle en fait en tout cas
discipline carrefour c'est à dire pas
une discipline en plus mais une
discipline qui peut être au carrefour de
toutes les autres disciplines reconnues
reconnu qu'en dont l'utilité est revenu
voilà les échecs sont socialement
reconnue d'utilité publique à la qualité
éducative
oui voilà ça pas de ça pas de traduction
concrète
évidemment c'est un texte cadre mais
justement à l'intérieur de ce texte
cadre après chaque recteur à la liberté
d'organiser ça comme il l'entend et le
fait est que c'est ce que fait jean
michel blanquer dans l'académie de
créteil
j'ai contact avec quelqu'un ici qui
travaillent à pau et qui va donner des
conférences sur les échecs en iufm ça
veut dire qu'il va toucher le futur
enseignant qui vont peut-être être
justement intéressés par cette démarche
donc ça peut ça peut éventuellement
essaimé dans toute la france et on peut
imaginer que cette expérience qu'une
expérience pilote dans se développe à
grande échelle
alors faut quand même pas oublier
d'accord ski non non non qui a été
évidemment précurseur sur ce bien sur le
terrain les fléaux battesti notamment
création et qui a démontré que ben ça
pouvait se déployer à grande vitesse et
qui est bon mais peut-être qu'ils
gardent évident il faut du temps après
pour voir les résultats puisque un
enfant de 10 ans qui apprend à jouer on
peut voir vraiment si ça ne désigne pas
que quand il y en aura dix huit sur war
zéro du temps il va falloir c'est
construire les outils pour mesurer cette
progression oui bah c'est pas clair il
ya tout un tout un domaine aussi qui
doit se développer c'est la recherche
autour des échecs
oui
là je suis en contact avec un chercheur
qui s'appelle philippe classique et au
cnrs et qui va lancer une étude sur
l'impact que peuvent avoir les échecs
sur les enfants mais à plus grande
échelle savoir entre les joueurs
d'échecs et ceux qui le voient là ils
cessent de nos joueurs est un groupe de
joueurs je crois qu'il ya déjà eu ce
genre d'étude ski michel noir a démontré
aussi qu'il y avait des brimades sur la
mémoire la concentration c'est une étude
qui a le mérite d'exister d'autant
qu'elle est menée par quelqu'un qui a
une grande notoriété publique
le seul souci c'était peut-être que
l'échantillon était assez restreint et
que l'étude était peut-être pas assez
menée sur assez de temps il a fait dans
le cadre d'une thèse là en l'occurrence
qui serait intéressant c'est d'avoir
effectivement une étude plus longue sur
un plus grand échantillon dans toute la
france à ce que font d'amendé c'est ce
qui est en train de se monter justement
avec ces chercheurs du cnrs ça c'est
très intéressant alors tu vas revenir
une troisième fois parce que c'est ta
deuxième apparition pour ce chorus une
troisième fois pour le chorus on parlera
précisément plus précisément de cette de
cette étude très importante et on
parlera aussi de ski des s'est déjà fait
notamment de ce café michel noir
l'université de lyon alors on va parler
aussi d'une offre de thé de tes
habitudes de 2t actualité tu es aussi
auteur et alors tu viens de tu viens de
créer une pièce qui est actuellement la
comédie saint-michel jusqu'au 2 mai qui
se nomme alors période des transferts
peut-être on peut la voir
merci la régie voilà père des transferts
donc par éric darrière et donc et jérôme
mouhot firme on fera donc une pièce
alors le comique
oui c'est plutôt une comédie que même
s'il ya des moments un peu plus
intimiste dans l'ensemble ne prête pas
spécialement à la mélancolie
voilà donc l'idée c'est en gros c'est
des gens qui se retrouvent pour pouvoir
match de foot seulement et puis vont
tout faire sauf regarder le foot en
notre slogan c'est un peu une soirée
foot ça sert à tout sauf à regarder du
foot - discuter de leurs femmes de leur
travail de leurs parents leurs enfants
de leurs soucis de leurs espoirs
et c'est assez je pense que c'est assez
réaliste ça reflète bien ce que peuvent
penser imaginer espérer des jeunes
jambes je veux dire jeunes gens sont un
peu plus que les autres de 35 ans avait
tout à fait période des transferts alors
pour pourvoir cette cette pièce qui
s'annonce tout à fait alléchante
peur du transfert donc c'est à la
comédie saint michel et vous pouvez
réserver vos places donc c'est le jeudi
vendredi samedi jusqu'au 2 mai à 20h30 à
21h30
comédie saint-michel au 01 55 42 92 97
01 55 42 92 97 réserver vos places pour
les voir cette pièce de jérôme nous fera
bien le petit rapport avec les échecs je
pense maintenant mais on est en face du
jardin du luxembourg
bien sûr donc ceux qui bravent le froid
ou même puisqu'on joue jusque jusqu'au 2
mai qui auront l'occasion de jouer
quelques parties au luxembourg peuvent
aller directement aussitôt terre c'est
vrai c'est formidable c'est vrai que nos
cerveaux faut rappeler qu'il ya au
jardin des tables des chèques
effectivement est allé nombreux joint
par le sénat depuis quelques années déjà
on était d'ailleurs dire aux dates et
les terres l'onu l'inauguration de ces
tables ça devait être un an de mine il y
avait une petite simultanée exprès pour
pour ce pour cela alors donc on va voir
aujourd'hui notre parti du jour de ce
chorus 2009 alors une très très belle
partie où on va apprendre beaucoup
beaucoup de choses c'est une partie
d'entre 20 ue le chinois les chinois de
plus en plus fort avant 2007 139,1 donc
c'est parce que vous imaginez mais c'est
colossal qu'on classement
c'est surtout un hello stratosphérique
par rapport au niveau des chinois il ya
20 ans voilà c'est surtout ça la chine
n'a jamais été une grande nation et
chicken pour plusieurs raisons la
première c'est que le jeu d'échecs tel
qu'on le pratique en europe ne se
pratique pas traditionnellement ne se
pratiquait déjà pratiqué par la gdi
traditionnellement vont être auditionnés
il ya la concurrence d'autres d'autres
jeux de stratégie comme le groupe comme
ce gros rock par exemple évidemment donc
les échecs n'ont jamais été
extraordinairement développer en chine
en dépit de l'amitié qui a existé avec
une en soviétique ne va pas durer
peut-être suffisamment longtemps en tout
cas de la chine s'est mise aux échecs
depuis quelques temps avec les résultats
qu'on sait puisque maintenant on a des
grands maîtres internationaux chinois
masculin et féminin
oui qu'ils sont nombreux je crois que
des accords ont été signés d'ailleurs
entre la fff et la fédération chinoise
d'hivernage franchir match france chine
qui avait été organisée par la
fédération il ya deux ans bien sûr donc
c'est une nation qui qui s'éveille à
l'instar de l'inde qui est maintenant un
champion du monde demain champion du
monde
comme ces deux nations bah elles ont
montré des années 90-2000 leur potentiel
et elles ont elles se sont réveillées
économiquement oui elle se réveille
aussi au plan et chic n ya pas de hasard
mais les ponots au 19e siècle c'est la
france et l'angleterre qui dominait les
échecs au 20e siècle on a eu l'urss et
les états unis avec bobby fischer
guillou a demandé à la chine et l'inde
voilà c'est pas on ne sait pas
exactement c'est pas anodin et puis on
remonte encore même à l'époque de donc
mais monsieur de la grande du grand
empire espagnol de charles quint c'était
encore les espagnols qui dominait la
scène mondiale et à l'époque de la
renaissance les italiens exactement
nokia pas ya pas de hasard le seul échec
suit les grandes évolutions sociétales
et économiques alors les chinois très
très fort maintenant donc value qui fait
même partie du top 10
alors que je ne connaissais pas du tout
viande pour toulon je suis même pas sûr
de voir à quoi il ressemble le chez les
filles on a eu dix fans ce qu'il y a
vice-champion du monde elle a perdu
juste face à costil ou qu'elle a à peine
15 ans donc c'est sans doute très
certainement une nouvelle judit polgar
on va on va certainement la voir dans le
top 50 30 toutes catégories ça fait
ensemble ça a l'air de faire aucun doute
si elle a l'air en plus très motivé pour
ça donc les chinois han han force
maintenant bon ils sont face quand même
à une tradition échiquéenne plus que
centenaire notamment les ukrainiens les
russes et la sévère muse ou face à
vassily ivanchuk sans doute un des plus
grands génies du vieux d'échec je crois
notamment il ya quelques années il avait
battu quel sport en façon absolument
époustouflante alors que kasparov était
quasiment au top à l'époque c'est un
reste parmi les joueurs d'échecs c'est
un peu l'un des chouchous on va dire
mais je crois que c'est un des génies
quoi je pense avec peut-être morose
évite aussi qui fait kiffer moins de
plaisir à voir c'est en tout cas une
façon de traiter de jeu d'échecs qui est
qui et qui enthousiasmante
il trouve toujours des idées souvent
souvent extraordinaires effectivement
c'est un des joueurs qui posent le plus
de problèmes kasparov peut-être le seul
le seul barrage qui a fait qu'il vente
ou qu'il n'est pas devenu champion du
monde c'est sa nervosité seulement mais
à part ça au niveau du talent c'est un
joueur qui a battu tout le monde tout
simplement et qui est capable de battre
tout le monde mais qui craque un peu
souvent simplement quand l'enjeu est
trop important
alors on voit ici c'est parti entre 20
millions et ivantchouk et ça démarre
avec le coût des quatre donc ouverture
du tournoi par le par le chinois câble
docsis ces cas dont coup classique
comprend le centre ont contrôlé quatre
centrales
le sis de la part d'une chute kabir
trois des cinq réaction normale au
centre on se développe on met les pieds
au centre
ensuite on va développer les pièces
autour de ce centre de pions ou g5 conte
classique comprend sec a donc déjà une
décision d'i want to this il a prise en
c4 qui nous amène dans un des bus déjà
tendu parce que si les blancs ne
reprennent pas le tout de suite les
noirs vous pouvoir le protéger par b 5
avec une dissymétrie au niveau des pions
contre un centre de pions blancs qui
pourrait devenir fort avec des 4 et
ensuite quatre c'est parce que justement
je vais vous évite cette variante ah oui
et il est vrai que de manière générale
c'est ce qu'on conseille aux jeunes
joueurs c'est de conserver l'attention
au centre de ne pas être le premier à
prendre
et là en l'occurrence ça donne le
sentiment que les noirs donne entre
guillemets le centre aux blancs moelleux
leurs pions des ne contrôle plus 4 et on
considère toujours que dans les
ouvertures du pion dames il est
hasardeux de vouloir ensuite
s'accrochait ce pion c'est donc varier
choisi la variante peut-être la plus la
moins dangereuse n'a plus le plus
tranquille dans ma quatrième pour
récupérer directement le pion que c'est
l'idée de base
si les noirs jouent le coup food et
c'est tout simplement prend le plus
éclatant alors là il va de soi que
choisit même un autre coup cavaliers b
en 17 donc c'est pas la même idée il
sent pas le foot mais le cavalier donc
les blancs sont pas obligés de reprendre
tout de suite le pion le pion c4 c'est
pourquoi avant de le reprendre tout de
suite il faut d'abord le coup qu'a
laissé 3 pourquoi parce que calais c'est
juan idées pour dans dix ou c'est de
jouer eux quatre le câble et protégeant
bien la case de quatre cas les six peut
pas prendre mais si les noirs jouent à 6
lorsque obligé dans ce cas là de donner
le fou contre lecavalier avant de
protéger le pied de 4
sinon un projet surtout h4 g5 on
perdrait le pion et entendre et donc la
paire de fou donc c'est forcément ce
qu'on veut faire donc a blessé trois
d'abord menacent eux quatre et là ils
vont tous que joue le couple le plus le
plus tendu sans doute à 6 menace tout
simplement le bcs est suivie d'un câble
et b6 qui attaquent la dame qui seront
obligés de bouger par exemple ce genre
de trucs
les noirs ont toujours une vue sur la
casse des saints qui provoque si une
fois qu'ils sont je le cavalier en b 6
bien sûr vous revenez ensuite se cassent
des 5 et là l'idée c'est de jouer et de
protégé surprotégé si on s'écarte
alors bon en fait y'a pas de vrai
problème direct parce que
comme on va le voir ailleurs comme vous
ne reprend pas toujours par le pion
s'éclate puisqu'ils jouent g3 alors
pourquoi mais parce que le couple et 5
est encore prématuré malgré de quoi 6
puisque le cavalier c3 peut prendre en
v5 et en cas de prise évidemment c'est
la torah 8 qui sonne donc ya pas de
problème mais ils vont tous que le joue
quand même alors ça c'est sûr qu'on
reste voilà ce qu'un jour il ya des
règles qui sont pour tous les joueurs
d'échecs sauf pour ceux qui arrivent à
s'en affranchir c'est à ça qu'on
reconnaît les grands joueurs
les règles existent pour tout le monde
sauf pour le grand joueur qui va quand
même jouer ce coup qui a l'air mauvais
keller faible et on va voir vend mieux
qui va qui va demander la preuve quand
quand un joueur joue un coup inattendu
qui a l'air faible le smi qui en face
soit entre guillemets va se dégonfler
soit va dire ben maintenant contre moi
pourquoi tu la joues étant bien sûr donc
on va voir sa cavale et prendre des
scènes de la part de mieux donc
évidemment il en dessous ne reprend pas
puisqu'il ya la tour a vite compris
alors c'est quoi son idée parce que si
on perd ce pion b5 a pris la route si le
cavalière vient de comprendre qu'ils ont
ces quatre on aura perdu un gros pions
dans l'idée des 25 est la suivante
tomber vite
voilà pour lui donc la mélangeuse menace
effectivement de prendre en bessin la
dame ne peut pas évident de prendre ces
six puisque nous faut c'est vide protège
et derrière bas égal tombé 2 voilà voilà
l'idée tout simplement on peut quand
même je voulais 5 à cause de cette
tactique
à noter aussi que le coup j'ai trois
pouvaient s'avérer pénible puisque enfin
g2 pouvez taper sur la torah 8 en jouant
autour du temps plus on enlève ses
potentielles menaces absolument alors
peut ajouter un dernier point aussi
c'est que le fou qui se trouve en fuite
pourraient se développer avec gain de
temps et éventuellement venant faire
échec en v4 ce qui forcerait peut-être
pas mais qui quasiment un fou des deux
oui et l'eau ce qui permettrait ensuite
au noir de développer de l'activité
puisque leur fouille alors calmement m6
sera plus du tout cloud est bon pour
jouer qu'à bilbao a relevé de 4 à 5
il ya une idée derrière une idée forte
derrière ce coup apparemment étrange
alors à noter que sur le coup cavale et
ses trois co aurait pu tenter 28 août
très certainement les noirs tout
simplement ouvrir récupérer une b2 avec
une belle position maintenant puisque
les blancs ont des problèmes sur cases
noires le plombier de ayant sauté la
menace des quatre deviennent devient
pénible bon
prendre le pion c4 et plus tellement
forcément facile à envisager donc les
noirs plus trop de problèmes
ils n'ont pas peur de jouer cette
variante alors benbiou c'est de trouver
dans cette position donc une variante
qui paraît quand même dangereuse mais
intéressante car il ya sept
ça c'est pas mal ça c'est intéressant
peut-être un peu tendu alors l'idée de
calais 7 c'est de viser la casse et six
étages
et le pire c'est que la dame est enfermé
et la d'habitants fermeront d un peut
pas sortir en tête puisqu'il serait
prise aussi donc il faut que les gens
réagissent de façon puissante à ce coup
là le désavantage par contre du coup
cavaliers à 7 c'est qu'il est enfermé ce
cavalier mais mais il attaque le fou
c'est vite dit et l'autre idée de ce que
nous qui supprimerait un four et
affaiblir et puis on a six l'inter
qu'après la prise en c4 on pourrait
jouer envisager par exemple 4 foot
procès car le bio insiste au s'avérer
faible
et puis les blancs ont quand même le
projet avec après avoir changé trois de
jeu leur foi en g2 est de rayonner sur
les cases blanches ci se débarrasse du
fou si vite et ça permet de concrétiser
cet objectif lancer débarrassant du fou
si justement exactement donc le coup
d'oeil du groupe donc c'est là qu'il
faut suivre l'idée d'yves en dessous
tour des quatre attaques la lada mac
adam coûts intermédiaires mais le
problème c'est que ça enlève pas pour
l'instant tout de suite la fourchette on
sait si ce alors vous allez voir la
suite qui est maligne de la part d'ubs
en dessous qu alors d'abord value j'ai
pour mon dire je pense qu'on est devant
nous alors dire on va dire bongo est ce
qu on y arrive voilà footpro f6 d'abord
intermédiaire choisi d'éliminer colère
en virant si on prend de la dame
le fou s'évitera emprise totale du
cavalier mais elle pas l'idée donc on
reprend il a repris du projet n'a pas
repris
garder un contrôle sur le trouvais parle
donc ici dame à 5,5 et la menace des
blancs et c'est la fourchette une
fourchette en c6 donc juste à temps ici
faux bessette a noté un vide a mentionné
les prix la dame foot 17 on se reportera
dawn princess est il fou bessette et là
je contrôle a cassé 6 et en plus je me
mets en vis-à-vis potentiel du futur fou
g2 donc j'ai un très bon fond et il faut
simple j'ai pas donné et la structure
noir allaient assez éclatée les
structures de pions noirs comptent déjà
deux qui ont doublé sur la colonne est
fait sur la colonne c'est oui mais en
définitive garn équilibre dynamique qui
se crée on voit que le cavalier défend
beaucoup de cases importante le fou mais
se faisaient observer 17 oui tout à fait
cavalier 17 contre beaucoup de cases
donald père de foot on à la paire de fou
ça c'est important parce que ce fou
rayonne regarder et puis le faut et suit
est très bien aussi
il peut même sortir de l'autre côté à
terme tard il pourra sortir l'autre côté
éventuellement même si c'est pas une
position très orthodoxe et le et le pion
b2 et dans les antilles et des allemands
ont finalement des problèmes les
problèmes et les besoins des problèmes
et puis le car il ya sept étaient fermés
ça fait beaucoup de choses à penser donc
la position droite est en équilibre
dynamique les charges ça ça fait des
structures contre un gros dynamisme
on voit bien d'ailleurs regardez les
pièces sorties 1 2 3 4 4
non il n'est pas sorti mais il est
tellement actif qu'on a un peu subi les
actifs en tout cas voilà trois presque 4
ici et là on a deux pièces trois pièces
avec un curly mal placé donc un cavalier
3 qui n'a pas beaucoup de perspectives
parce que le pion j'ai filé peut-être
doubler mais ils contrôlent les cases du
cavalier et réservations très efficace
tout à fait tout à fait il n'empêche
qu'avec bougies le monde ils dominent
domine ce cavalier ou peut aller ce
clavier pas grand chose pas pas beaucoup
de cases peut même pas envisager de
bouger en d2 ou h4 puisqu'il façon le
foot 17 pour l'instant qu'un flou donc
pas évident
pas mal c'est cette conception dimanche
très intéressante donc la value trouve
une idée de développement fou h3 bien
joué on se met pas en vis-à-vis du
fourbe et cet ouvrage 3 pourquoi pas
pour commencer à taper sur ie6 on sait
jamais l'idée devant liu s'est peut-être
devenir sera 5,6 le plus rester cloué il
ya une menace sur mon système
intéressant serait une bien mauvaise
idée pour les noirs de prendre le
cavalier ou f3 puis ce qu'ils aient
changé de nom il faut pas prendre contre
un contrat cavaliers et ça ouvre la
colonne s'affaiblissent et 6 affaibli la
classe c 6 qui sont contrôlés et puis ça
donnerait père de fou c'est ça le saut
cavalière 3 est bien moins important que
ce flou absolu qui tiennent tout métier
toutes les cases blanches donc faux h3
très important donc la ive en dessous
mais n'en profite du fait que ce
cavalier bas et un problème où il va
dans le beat voile pour un ukrainien il
veut partir à la moisson exacte et
l'abbatiale cavalli d'affaires d'où
l'intérêt d'un v8 j'attaque le cavalier
à 7
et en plus je mets la dame derrière la
tour pour créer une pression
supplémentaire sur lyon b2 et on a un
problème et blanc parce que car y'a pas
de cannes alors donc cela c'est l'idée
qu'on voit deux fois je 3,20 view en
fait dans cette position juste ici est
déjà mal en est déjà là bizarrement il
est déjà mal
la positionnement est très très
dynamique et le chaos les assets
finalement et pas forcément bien placé
donc fourrage trois dames b8 très
puissant yvonne shoots ouverts cavaillé
n'y a pas de case donc venu où va se
lancer mais non dans une attaque et a
pas vraiment le choix il n'a pas le
choix il va lancer un ordinateur quand
vous allez voir l'idée devant le but où
tout de suite il joue damage 5 voilà
alors c'est pas mal c'est une bonne idée
l'idée c'est que donc c'est ce qu'ont
indiqué tout à l'heure le pion au fc st
cloud et est donc je donne à ce fou
prend 1,6 et après je vais me venger je
vais y compris prendre le pian et c'est
avec échec avec la dame est là du coup
ça vaut facilement une pièce parce qu'on
a le roi qui est des rockets on a pris
au moins deux pions il ya des qui ont
fait partout c'est une position qui
commence à devenir intéressante pour les
blanquettes bonnes perspectives pour les
blancs de pouvoir au moins récupérer le
matériel voit l'artiste n'est créé une
attaque si puissante que eelv en dessous
doivent abandonner
donc là il faut pas se presser pour
prendre le cas mediaset et donc ils vont
tous que vit dans le voit que cette
menace est beaucoup trop forte ou qui
jouent le coup plus tranquille
roy au 7 mai on jouera en deux sets
alors évidemment on peut plus prendre
aux 600 sans avoir un pion qui peut
reprendre
enfin on n'a pas de problème il n'y a
plus de clouage mai mais le câble et à
sète a toujours pas de gaz 1 pour les
blancs et alors le point que pour les
noirs lui lancer maintenant le roi est
au centre le fouet suite du coupé est
moins actif aussi il
non là on a bloqué à la fois le fou ils
à tours il faut que les blancs essayer
de contrecarrer ce problème qu'ils ont
une cassette avec un surcroît d'activité
alors maintenant que faire d'une
certaine façon et les noirs nations en
raison de prendre leur temps dans la
mesure où de toute façon le cavalier
blanc à 7 est bloquée petits blocs et
donc ils auront tout le temps de le
prendre un autre moment exactement il
n'y a pas de y'a pas de plan jamais seul
voilà faut jamais se presser pas se
presser il vaut mieux d'abord défendre
consolidé c'est ce que fait devant le
choc même si roy set ça a l'air un petit
peu particulier comme coup oui c'est le
meilleur dans cette position et en
l'occurrence à lui permettent de
défendre et donc alors position complet
comme vous voyez mes donc toujours cet
avantage dynamique fort de la part du
nord alors là le coût des ventes de 28
intéressant des cinq salles au cerveau
voilà c'est très joli très joli coup
alors regardez qu'est ce qu'ils viennent
faire le pion en dessin qu'il veut
casser la structure ou blanche ici alors
oui mais en fait vous on peut se dire
mais attendait une fille on peut le
prendre qu'une façon différente du pion
du fou alors déjà si on prend du plomb
mais sinon qu'est ce qui se passe tout
simplement fou conclave alliés et a pris
roi prend tout simplement on peut faire
par exemple damev cinq échecs et suroît
eaux cette
on peut suivre ont regardé par le coup
cac valeo 5 avec une menace ici de venir
en 17 matchs et si on prend un dessin
comprendre la dame avec échec et c'est
la torah fuite qui va sauter qu'il soit
donc c'est une petite combinaison
possible on peut prendre entre sept
on peut envisager aussi prendre à vii
alors ça permettrait de sortir le fouet
fuite
c'est peut-être pas la meilleure attaque
est pas le meilleur
voilà mais voilà cette combinaison ici
et si si on joue un coût moyen on pourra
jamais prendre le cavalier tout de suite
à cause de la combinaison
dans ce cas les très puissants ici tout
est cassé en plus regardés on crée une
menace de fourchette
voilà alors on arrive à sauver kavanagh
rival indien
voilà on peut créer après quatre échecs
fou prend cavale et prend et on récupère
la tour b 4 - au moins la qualité
donc c'est une combinaison intéressante
alors on peut donc prendre du plomb et
dangereux cause du fait que comme ça on
dévie on élimine un défenseur du mois
puisqu'ils n'ont un défenseur alors si
on prenait maintenant du fou qu'est ce
qui se passe sur vous prend des cinq
regarder de façon très surprenante on
peut prendre le fou de la dame
pourquoi parce que l'idée c'est que le
fou contrôler la quasi ci qui fait
fonctionner ensemble gagner c'est ça
l'idée on sauve le cavalier c'est ça
qu'il faut comprendre mon cavalier ces
six échecs et un risque permanent échec
donc par exemple 3 en d6 puisque quand
on arrive en finale on n'a pas trop de
problèmes et là hop on récupère lada on
a beau parler prix fous là une dame et
les noirs ont pris un cavalier et une
âme bon par exemple on prend du cavalier
pour par exemple venir en c6 bilan des
courses ici les noirs ont quand même
deux pions on peut faire grand rôle pour
bien sauvegarder
ici le truc leroy nord et au centre pour
essayer de casser cette case en dessin
au niveau des structures des pions elle
est tellement cassé que les blancpain
espérons au moins égaliser oui parce
qu'en plus leur cavalier peut rapidement
sauté en d4 f5 surtout au soir des 400
ash 95 de ses american rebel canon ef 5
qui refuse donc il peut pas être un
avant poste au rêver parce que les noirs
n'ont plus de fougue blanc pour se
débarrasser du cavalier ni l'opinion ni
de puriste de saison bien sûr pour le
chasser donc c'est pour ça que c'est une
belle case et il est protégé par le
fauche 3 voilà une qui a toujours une
case avancer comme ça qui est attaquable
par un pion ça s'appelle un avant poste
si en plus vous êtes devant une pure ça
empêche les pièces courtes d'attaqué et
c'est pour prendre car et lycéens
toujours une position rêvée voilà c'est
une position à laquelle le cavalier pour
largement largement plus que sa valeur
nominale
voilà donc on voit que ces deux idées
fou prend des cinq permis aux sacrifices
de dames et donc de sauver le camélia c
est finalement et comprend des scènes
permin communisants a pas de vous
prendre 17 et un affaiblissement du roi
noir donc ce coup d'essai qui fort pour
d'autres raisons
c'est qu'il permet de donner la case des
4o cavale mais aussi blanc cavaliers
pourraient envisager de venir
effectivement cette caste des cadres à
la rescousse du sur la caisse et si ce
sont deux années de son partenaire de
son partenaire donc lille en dessous
quand profite maintenant de faire
profiter élimine nallo cavalia c'est
comme ça on n'en parle plus ils gobent
la pièce ivantchouk voilà nous l'apprend
et en plus avec saddam contrôler la case
des quatre dont on vient de parler ils
contrôlent la place des quatre en plus
il empêche effectivement le coutelier
des quatre exactement et il a enfin
éliminer ce que petit cali qui s'est
aventuré et la vanille ou doit
absolument maintenant avoir un jeu très
dynamique on comprend pour récupérer sa
bien aimée en fait toute la question de
savoir est ce que la taxe suffi à
contrecarrer cette pièce de moins mais
c'est ce qu'on va voir
et c'est pas évident alors puis on prend
des six évidemment l'idée c'est
d'affaiblir la position du voile à des
mouroirs exactement donc la reprise du
pion i want to kill trop content d'avoir
d'options maintenant relier si vous
voulez parce que c'était des pions
doublé c'est jamais très bon donc
et là il se lance de façon est perdu
dans l'attaqué avec fu prendre six
entrepreneurs nom kick-ass le dernier
rempart et il faut éviter damev cette
échelle bien sûr qui sera un désastre
parce que très vite après tour d un il
ya quasiment un math rapide qui va
tomber qu'il faut de seulement il faut
prendre le fou faut accepter la prime
est ivre il lui prend tout ça lui fait
deux pièces de plus donc il peut rentrer
du matériel et il sait que les blancs où
commençait à être à court de matériel
pour attaquer parce que notre cavalier 3
ne peut pas venir en des cartes et peut
toujours pas venir en 5 peut toujours
pas venir angers 5 et en définitive des
la dame seule ne peut pas on ne va pas
mener une attaque de nattes exactement
alors ceci étant dit il ya dans le huit
échecs
voilà ce qu'a vu vendu aux ce qu'a vu le
new d'un 8 échecs froid est là le roi un
problème parce que vous allez alors il
danse il vient et 5 c'est pas bon à
cause de calais h quatre échecs et très
vite il peut y avoir un math maintenant
parce que là ça devient même si matt
sans doute il ya encore qu'elle va lier
encore projet 4 jeudi mais avec l'âge
jusqu'à quel point j'ai 5 et l'a gardé
tout simplement f4 rocher 4 et on prend
le cas lié avec échec et on voit très
vite que le roi est très mal donc c'est
pas bon donc dans huit échecs il faut
rendre la tour donc fawcett
je rappelle que les noirs deux pièces de
plus donc il a rendu nos recettes
certaines tours mais ils ont quand même
deux pièces mineurs pour la tour et
malgré la position un peu short envie de
dire l'athée du roi notamment ils n'ont
pas vraiment de problème les noirs parce
que il aurait plus de problème si le
pion et n'existait pas parce que les
détours pourrait venir au centre mais là
c'est pas le cas la tour pourra jamais
venir faire un échec ici il manque du
matériel aux blancs tout simplement pour
pour monter une attaque donc après dame
prend tour et le très joli car les
fuites qui enferme la dame lors des
protège le cavalier de cette control
contrôle tout contrôle ce cavalier en
même temps protéger par le soudan qui
tiennent bien la position
il verrouille la position dure ambiance
toujours bien d'avoir un cavalier à kout
à proximité du roi c'est jamais facile
de l'attaqué après ce très joli coup que
les fuites de consolidation ab
bandiougou faire dame g8 échec roi 17
grand roque échec 3,8
c'est fini et aussi bizarre que ça
puisse paraître avec la position
précaire du roi noir la structure de
pions éclater des pièces dans tous les
sens une dame qui est excentré brasse
est bien soutien soutien est en fait le
problème c'est que c'est des blancs même
qu'ils vont devoir souffrir parce qu'il
ya quand même une paire de fou un
cavalier défensif qui maintient la dame
je dirais en respect il ya aucun avec
une kabylie proche du roi la dame peut
jamais l'attaqué en fait ce qu'il peut
mais comprendre ça défend très bien à un
cavalier lui aussi signé g6 on peut pas
venir aussi peut pas venir justifer des
échecs le carlit par les échecs à la
fois horizontaux et aussi des collègues
donc c'est très délicat il manque des
pièces au blanc pour attaquer et la dame
va pouvoir venir en b6 commencé à
titiller b2 le fou cette peut avoir une
influence sur les classements ici le fou
bessède maintient toujours une pression
terrible ici puis en plus venu peut
venir éventuellement quatre plus tard
pour faire d échec éventuel sursaut va
laisser les noirs qui sont les plus
actifs dans cette position d'autant que
l'anglo a repris un peu de matériel
reprenant la tournée c'était un tour qui
ne jouait pas de toute façon et il se
retrouve le même avec une tour qui ne
jouent pas en sachant qu'ils n'exercent
pectives et un quadrillage 3 qui est
bouclée bouger oui parce qu'il peut pas
ne peux pas m'y rendre
elle pourrait si elle est pas ce pion il
restreint et ça serait toutefois là mais
on ne sait pas où serait cavalier qui
serait en prison donc il faudrait qu'il
soit ailleurs il faudrait que le
cavalier soit là qui est pas de piquant
et que la tour puisse venir là mais a
fait beaucoup pour un seul c'est pas la
position et sylvain tout cas très bien
jugé très bien jugé cette position donc
la value ces deux
il de voir que bay hill comment il va
avoir des problèmes ici parce que très
vite d'un v6 pression ici ces trois peut
aussi casser la structure du rendement
qui lui-même est sous pression
donc il ramène des pièces d'alger quatre
décès c'est bien déjà de d'essayer de
ramener la dame par exemple en d4 et
d'essayer de faire des échanges parce
qu'il a il a une pression sur son roi
dame c'est celle de la part d'ibm tchouk
alors avec l'idée tout de suite déjà
d'avoir gardé une petite batterie
un homme fou que n'a peut-être pas vu
d'ailleurs l'idée c'est de pouvoir
prendre b2 peut-être et de venir faire
un échec en trois ans qu'il est là alors
c'est déjà très délicat pour marier ou
qui étaient en difficulté sur parce que
la menace aussi c3 c3 imaginez un coup
comme par exemple d'amd 4 de la part
d'amis disant bon j'ai essayé d'échanger
les dames et de tenir
eh bien on pourrait jouer quand même si
trois de la part des noirs si la dame
prend évidemment heureux tour c4 courage
et si la dame de france et ça si on
prend assez simple tout simplement fou
procès sec
on a un problème sur le pont-neuf 2 on
peut pas protéger part aux trois parce
que c'est le fou c'est le cavalier qui
eux mêmes ont peu avant de reprendre la
dame qui saute quand même de reprendre
la dame et la possibilité d'un procès 5
oui bien sûr on peut aussi faire sur
dame français sont tous également qu' on
prend les deux échecs et ensuite on
prend la dame ensuite on prendra mais là
ça fait beaucoup en b2 très très fort
donc pas évident alors que l'anglais ou
fait sans doute la dernière heure de la
partie qui le coût à 3 alors à 3 fait
une erreur en tout cas affaiblissement
regardez c'est le rêve pour yvonne tout
le sacrifice de évident il le fait tout
de suite d'ailleurs tour contre b2 et
aura des le roi blanc qui est
complètement à nu ces sacrifices à
bruxelles et physique en dessous très
jolie roi prend b2 devant liu qui est un
coup désespéré parce que les médecins
sont déjà c'est la position et
et puis voyez comme c'est comme ces
extraordinaires ces voyous qualité de
mon île natale maintenant la pulsion
d'idées noires étaient très très forte
et très saine en fait on voit que même
la dame angers depuis g4 ne peut pas
donner échec ans et vite c'est encore le
flou bessette qui protège ses lequel
aucune case même h5 servir à rien
puisque de toute façon maintenant il y
avait cinq ou six d'ailleurs qui empêche
ce moment le seul échec alors c'est pour
cela sans doute qu'il ya du coup si elle
risque ou parce que ça empêche le coup
d'un match 5 échecs qui était quand même
souci puisque le roi peut pas aller à
gauche et comme si ce serveur qu'adam
parle c'est comme ces cinq étaient aussi
dans cette idée la défense il était à la
fois un peu offensif et défensif
laura 3 nos réseaux rien tout reprendre
les deux extraordinaires et ce roi prend
b2 de deuil ou simplement ils voient
tout continue par dame en a trois échecs
à b1 dame b 3 échecs et déjà on n'a pas
trop le choix parce que il joue un vous
déjà au moins 25 ans - là nul mais il a
mieux que ça puisque après ses 3 et
abandonneront pourquoi parce que le
matin b2 est imparable tout simplement
les blancs pourrait jouer par exemple
damage cinq échecs qu'a balayé 6 le seul
coup pour paris le matin b de tomber à
ne sert pas parce qu'il y aurait dans ma
trois matches seul coup ce serait de
jouer dans ma 5 qui empêche damas trois
mais qui n'a jamais rien donné
on peut pas empêcher les deux faudrait
jouer un coup comme tours d2 le seul
coup oui qui parlait simplement un pion
prendre menace dame
et sur cavaliers pros on prend la tour 1
y'a plus rien regardez c'est horrible à
nos maisons oui non en fait un échec
d'abord un échec d'abord un petit échec
en c3 1 pour la tour ont très jolie
combinaison finale du bpt en dessous et
on comprend que ben en fait tout s'est
joué dans cette conception
extraordinaire de jouer des scènes quand
même tombé huit et vingt view s'est
lancé dans une attaque comme un peu
désespérée et dont on a vu que ça suffit
pas c'est plutôt les noirs comme une
position saine et il a fallu lâcher la
tour comme l' attaque devant liu était
très décoratives très esthétique
il a trouvé des ressources pour essayer
de maintenir le feu de la tacc assez
nourris pour vous menacer immense choc
mais ce n'était pas suffisant ce
pourquoi maison parce qu'il a tout mais
c'est toujours retrouver finalement avec
juste la dame et on peut pas mener une
attaque à bien avec juste une pièce qui
il manquait quelque chose
et ce qui est extraordinaire dans la
position du vent de choc on le répète
c'est cette espèce d'apparence
d'éclatement qui a mais en fait une
position dynamique qui tiens oui avec un
très belle paire de fou avec une très
belle paire de fous sont incapables
placés de façon extraordinaire mais qui
qui rayonne sur les chiffres eux mêmes
c'est à un point b c et puis le fawcett
qui est qui qui lorgnait très bien vers
le roi blanc bien vu un première vue
lundi après regarde la position se
disent mais des fous sont bizarrement
placée le 7 à la défense du roi et puis
l'otan bessette qui al'air capallere
extraordinaire puis finalement si ils
sont vraiment très très fort qu'on voit
encore la force de l'idée générale aux
échecs de dire je sacrifie option pour
accéder dans mon développement b5
totalement inattendue et derrière vendus
qui a perdu un peu pierre est ce cette
idée cavaliers à 7 qui laissent là les
emprises finalement et 26 août a appris
le temps de
le gober au bon moment et on a vu voilà
cette très belle partie des ventes ou
belle démonstration l'envié ou reste un
très fort joueur qu'on reverra nasri
très certainement d'altérer on va
rappeler dans ta pièce germond fera la
comédie saint-michel à la comédie
saint-michel jusqu'au domaine période
des transferts
absolument et il faut tous les jeudis
vendredis et samedis samedi et on se
retrouve pour une autre émission chorus
pour la prochaine semaine où on va donc
continuer à avoir une très belle partie
et on parlera donc c'est de cette étude
cette étude qui est en cours d'être mené
dans l'académie de créteil donc pour le
développement du jeu d'échecs comme
outil pédagogique
merci jérôme et puis il ya ce beaucoup à
bientôt sur diagonale tv merci de nous
être fidèles et de soutenir notre
émission voilà bientôt revoir et à
bientôt